let's talk a little bit about Donald
Trump's recent sixty minutes interview
we had so much to cover
earlier this week that we didn't really
discuss it too much except in passing
and our friend Kyle kolinsky from
secular talk covered it in detail one of
the aspects he covered was Donald Trump
saying that I am fine with gay marriage
let's take a look at Kyle's coverage
president elect Trump which sounds weird
every time I say it spoke about the
issue of gay marriage and he took an
interesting new path one of the groups
that's expressing fear as the lbgtq
group that I mentioned I'm a big
Republican National Convention and yeah
everybody said that was so great
I have been you know I've been a
supporter well I guess the issue for
them is a marriage equality
do you support marriage equality is
irrelevant because it was already
settled it's long settled of the Supreme
Court and then it's done so even if you
appoint a judge that it's done it that
you have these cases have gone to the
Supreme Court they've been settled and
I'm talking with it interesting so I
have a lot to say on that first of all
good credit where credit is due that's a
much better answer than Rick Santorum
would give or Mike Huckabee would give
or Ted Cruz would give or any of the
really big-time social conservatives
would give so there's a massive upside
in that the second thing is you know
he's personally fine with gay marriage
because when he's asked about Roe versus
Wade and whether or not that needs to be
repealed he says yes okay but hold on
Don that's a settled case too so notice
the logic isn't the same for a gay
marriage he basically uses the logic
look at settled law they had the case
they came to their conclusion let's move
along here well that same reasoning
would be applied to Roe vs. Wade and
abortion but you didn't do that with
abortion you said well no that should be
looked at and I'm gonna appoint pro-life
judges and he even went on to say in the
interview
woman might have to go to another state
to get an abortion yeah I mean the the
broader point of what Kyle is discussing
here is what are Trump's personal views
versus how is Trump going to legislate
and this applies to many issues and I've
talked about this so many times before
and it actually also relates this whole
thing of what Trump can't personally be
anti-semitic or it would be weird if you
were because his daughters Jewish and
his son-in-law who he's very close to
his Jewish and his grandkids are Jewish
etc that is separate from the reality
that Trump has significantly emboldened
anti-semites and Jew haters and all
sorts of alt writers and white
nationalists in the KKK David Duke etc
it's pretty clear to me that Trump is
not religious at all but he's played up
the religion thing since becoming
candidate for president of the United
States and evangelicals turned out and
they voted for him and now the question
is well it no longer matters whether
it's whether Trump is personally
religious and likes the ideas of the
religious right I think as a lifelong
Democratic New Yorker he probably does
not really care for those ideas because
the evangelical vote helped to get him
elected and now there is going to be an
IOU there no doubt about it gay marriage
I have no doubt that Trump has never had
a problem with gay marriage his entire
life although now he has had to sort of
go back and forth and say is it a state
issue Supreme Court this that the other
thing I don't think that he is going to
really try to do anything in terms of
legislation on gay marriage but the real
relevant questions are things like
abortion we've heard from him on
abortion that well the woman shouldn't
get punished when he said that that was
wrong but roe v wade yeah I'm into
seeing that repealed by having the
Supreme Court justices which would look
at it bla bla bla bla bla I don't
believe for a second Trump's entire
thing about how now he is very pro-life
strongly pro-life because of some
incident that he had he's been
pro-choice his entire life and that is
probably a politically crafted position
and this applies to so many areas I deep
down think that Donald Trump played a
far more conservative character
conservative as maybe not even the right
word reactionary character during his
presidential campaign than who he really
is
but it almost doesn't matter
anymore because he got elected based on
those ideas and there are going to be
advisors look at look at who he has Mike
Pence and Steve Bannon and Newt Gingrich
and all of these others they are not
going to just allow Trump to forget all
the stuff that he said to get elected so
I don't know where the balance will be I
think Kyle is spot-on on this and it
comes down to Trump's opinion versus
Trump's public position only time will
tell we've seen at least on Obamacare
that there has been a very quick
backtracking we've seen on prosecuting
Hillary a very quick backtracking and
even on the wall probably will end up
being some fencing so that he can claim
victory on part of the border and Mexico
is not paying for a wall across the
entire border so I think that this is a
very relevant issue we'll be keeping
track right we know all the promises he
made and Trump made very specific
promises and we'll see how many of them
actually happen